President Trump is doubling down on his
threat to impose new trade tariffs on
Mexico he tweeted yesterday quote the
problem is that Mexico is an abuser of
the United States taking but never
giving last week the president announced
an initial five percent tariff on all
imports from Mexico if the country does
not stop illegal immigration to the US
the first round of those tariffs is due
to take effect on June 10th not too far
away CBS News business analyst Jill
Schlesinger is here with how this could
affect American businesses and your
wallet and my wallet and your wallet all
along but is all the wallet all the
wallets around Mexico was a major
trading partner of the u.s. what
products could be affected when I say
major the number one right now so we
export a lot we import a lot we import
close to 350 billion dollars worth of
goods and we're talking about everything
from automotive to auto parts
electronics fruits and vegetables so
strawberries raspberries tomatoes
avocados beer liquor even crude oil
which we are importing now so the real
concern here is because the list is so
vast that the price of these things
could rise and that would clearly not be
a good thing for consumers rise how fast
Joe well it really depends with the
product and how much yeah the fruits and
vegetables almost immediately because
they have very narrow margins I think
for a lot of the other things like a car
it would take a while but when you talk
about how much especially for the cars
there are some estimates that say that
the average auto at the 25% tariff level
so they would have to be in effect
through October that could make the car
on average fifteen hundred dollars more
expensive twenty five hundred on some
models exactly when you add all this up
it can it affect the broader economy
which is otherwise healthy yeah I mean
when you look at where we are right now
the economy is doing pretty well we had
a much stronger than expected first
quarter second quarter we're in right
now has slowed down some for the whole
year economists think we're going to
extend expand by about two and a half
percent if the full impact of these
tariffs were in effect some economists
believe that we could shave off a
quarter to a half of a percent of growth
so you are going to grow at two and a
half now
- you might say who cares how does that
affect me because if you're a business
you may not want to invest more in your
employees you may not want to give
raises you may not want to build a new
facility so this has real impact for
American workers it should also note
there are about five million jobs that
are linked directly to trade with Mexico
and the people in those industries are
very worried the innovative answer that
the potential fallout for the automakers
well the automakers is really
interesting because when you think about
a car that is let's say american-made
look under the hood so many parts come
from Mexico about 93 billion dollars
worth of automotive 17% of every u.s.
car somehow had some piece made in
Mexico and think about this because of
these supply chains basically free
flowing between Mexico the US and Canada
parts go back and forth many times so if
we were to see retaliation all of this
can escalate it's why we know that the
Mexican authorities have said we want to
avoid this at all costs it would be bad
for both sides if the price of beer and
avocado goes up over the summer I don't
see how that's politically good for the
president or the price at the pump again
yes which is also possible yeah very big
impact I'm focusing on the avocados
you're right Thank You Jill